I'll start off broad so of everything
all the big set pieces you had to film
for the movie
going into production which did you
think would be the most challenging to
actually execute and then ultimately was
that indeed the toughest thing to shoot
or did something else kind of Catch You
by surprise during production I think
the blood elevator was always the one
that um
that was kind of freaking me out because
I knew about the logistics of how it
could practically work
and the volume of blood that we needed
to create and the characters that I
needed to put in that space so that was
always a challenging one and it proved
to be you know heartbreaking along the
way you know in the best I suppose
possible like in the best way we could
approach it was to cross our fingers but
it was just not easy we had kept them to
return to it and get more and figure out
other technical ways and build a variety
of different like a Lego set elevator
that could come apart in different ways
and and build Special ways of having
pieces of blood because you couldn't
fill the whole place and there's it was
just a lot of technique and it was
always that thing like there was never a
production meeting that the blood
elevator didn't come up and it's like do
we really have to talk about this again
but it was yeah that was a big big
Challenge and I knew it would be and
then there's obviously there's a big bad
in the movie uh towards the end which is
yeah yeah oh yeah
there is there is the marauder and you
know the actual you know you know the I
wanted it to be as practical as I could
make it
and you know you can't really remove
people's organs for real to create space
for other people to crawl through their
bodies so that was something that um was
also incredibly incredibly challenging
we had to pull every trick possible to
bring that monster onto the screen like
everything I could ever think of that
you would do was was was applied and I
always knew that would be tough as well
and it was I'm gonna I'll go I'll go
directly to the The Marauder next and I
have like a million questions about this
creature first like I guess just from a
story perspective like why is that like
boss level deadite like what happens to
a dead eye that makes it more powerful
when they combine like that yeah I think
when if you look and if you if you kind
of follow the book in the movie as it
points out these different things that
take place or these different deadites
that come into the world the Marauders
actually planted really early on in the
movie The First Time The kids are
meddling with the book you see that
picture to me it's something that's
happened before and will happen again
and it depends on the circumstances what
I love about the evil force is that it's
it's undestroyable but at a deeper level
with this movie it's the worst version
of family you could imagine it's like if
you take the character of Beth right
who's someone that's unsure if she wants
to be a mother and maybe sees the the
danger of the shackles of that
um and then you take her and she's
presented with the all-encompassing
smothering it's like imagine that thing
hugging you would be like the worst hug
in the world it would wrap everything
around you so for me it wasn't just a
case of making something creepy and it
was also that idea for say a parent they
think some people might say I'll have
kids because someone will look after me
when I'm older they'll pick me up when I
fall down so Nelly loses an arm and a
leg and can't go after anybody her kids
come along and help her out and I always
thought that that was really Sinister
but it's it just really it was something
that I I hit on really early on and I
wanted there to be something that was
another level of spectacle another level
of Terror towards the end of the story
um and The Marauder showed its many
faces to me quite early great success
with that all right now now what about
like production and and effects what
what is something like that look like on
set during filming versus what's added
in post what's like at the core of it on
set it was multiple multiple layers to
create it so all of the actors that form
the marauder played a real part in that
and had to crawl and get into awkward
positions and be joined to another actor
at the same time and then there was also
stunt doubles that could double for them
that could actually move faster in this
there is a suit like there is a suit
that has been worn by that cast and then
there's some clever digital manipulation
to knit together some certain elements
of it and then we had to use motion
control cameras to do multiple passes of
that thing so the stunts would do a pass
one or two actors might do a past
tethered together one might do it on
their own so like we it took about a day
per Marauder shot almost in the movie it
add up a hell of a lot of time and um
yeah it was you know something that
you're really crossing your fingers with
I believed in the vision and the idea
but it was technically really
challenging but I think when you see it
on screen it's quite a spectacular
monster and it's something that we maybe
haven't seen some like quite like it
before can confirm I want to see b-roll
of that so badly have much of it so
badly I can't wait
um I want to go to something that Rob
had brought up during the premiere the
other night he he mentioned that a point
at a point there was a covid shutdown
and it gave you the opportunity to like
you know sit and think about what you
had and what you were going to make
going forward so I I guess like a
complicated two-parter on that when you
had that break to reflect on what you
had already shot is there anything that
you decided to go back to and bolster
for any particular reason but then also
for everything that's still lay ahead
for you guys what is something that
changed because you had a moment to
think it through and maybe refine the
plan even more well it's back to the
marauder because we Shot the movie in
chronological order and so we were in
the trenches with the Beast and you know
four o'clock in the afternoon someone's
like oh there's covert in New Zealand by
six o'clock set shut down by eight
o'clock that evening we've been told
we're shut down for two weeks which
extended into eight so I spent that time
working on the finale of the movie so I
got my storyboard artist re-engaged with
me I took footage redesigned shots cut
them in and created an animatic for the
end of the movie that I then brought
back on to set and and I think it
improved because I think that final 10
minutes downstairs in that basement is
quite a high point in the story it's
both it's both actiony and terrifying
and it's got emotion and it's got fear
but in a weird way it definitely gave me
the time to reflect but I never went
back and shot anything else that was it
we just went in maybe it was like the
second unit might have gone and got a
couple of other close-up pickup things
but all Focus was on finishing the movie
because that was our exit point at that
stage so cool you got to shoot in
sequence I feel like that is a luxury
most sets don't don't have and here I
could see how it could come in handy big
time I wanted to talk about the the
three necronomicons because I know you
have mentioned that each one has a
different personality so you know just
in your mind for your own head Cannon
right now can you give us kind of like
the 101 of each book and what makes it
different in terms of its personality
really I think Sam's book was the
original right and there was something
very basic like as in the very
beginnings and the origins of what it
was and then FedEx book I think showed a
certain brutality in kind of the way
it's designed and the way it's looked
and it had a methodology behind it also
in terms of giving a guidance to the you
know the amount of Innocence that's
taken and and how that might bring rise
to something into the world this book to
me is one that has a certain amount of
character and a little bit of life to it
in the sense that it actually activates
it moves it it drinks a little bit of
blood and I think each one of the books
I kind of look at them almost like
gospels in the Bible it's like the same
story until slightly different way by a
different person and who knows maybe
there's a fourth book out there oh I
like it maybe it's an inverse of
everything we know here's another thing
that I've kind of made up in my own head
it might not be real at all but is there
any situation where like if the books
come together they form the marauder
version but like of a book we discussed
that for fun on set I think it's
possible because all of these books
exist in the same world to me there is a
timeline that's linear from Sam's first
story all the way through to this it's
just happened to different people in
different places with different books I
have so many questions because I'm
obsessed with Ash versus evil dead did
you ever consider or will you consider
maybe incorporating more elements of
that show into the film franchise I I
love the show I adore the show it's
fantastic but I intentionally never used
it as a touch point for this because
there's so much in it I would have
drowned if you know what I mean and I
think there is a bit of a separation
with that that TV story that takes place
and the movies I was more interested in
the Canon of the movies when I was when
I was making Evil Dead Rises makes sense
I'm greedy I want every corner of my
Evil Dead franchise always I was reading
another quote that you had given where
you said something like you know you
were focused on making one good movie
but there were there were like four
different like unexplored Corners that
could lead to Future stories within what
you have created here I guess what like
one would be one would be Beth and
Cassie getting away another would be the
Necronomicon being left behind can you
Hint it what the other two are yeah well
we've also got what happens out at the
lake because as you look at this story
the beginning that you see is actually
the end of the movie right so what
happens out at that Lake could continue
like fresh people could show up at that
cabin not knowing the Carnage that just
took place there so that's another
pathway that interests me and the one
that I really like is the story of what
happened with the priests back in the
past
one priest versus a hundred deadites I'd
like to see that movie all right here's
my my last selfish question because you
you kind of like made this dare on
Twitter and now I wanted to figure it
out is Bruce Campbell one of the priests
Campbell is is a voice in that section
of the movie and someone hooked it and
got me last night on stage they quoted
the exact line so they won the 50 books
I love it I gotta find them somewhere
later on and give them what they deserve
I hate that I have to leave you right
now but you got more celebrating to do
congratulations
thank you for yet another great
installment of one of my favorite horror
franchises out there